[Music]
i think most people have a happy
halloween uh no halloween for the
president though did you hear this
president obama canceled the halloween
party at the white house
yeah obama canceled after hearing joe
biden was coming as [ __ ] joe biden
can't think of anything i'd rather less
see than [ __ ] joe bud it gets
everything all pushed up in here
that guy's got a rack uh
everyone car you have carved your
pumpkins you got that taken care of
all right
a company you might find this
interesting a company has come out with
a kit that's brand new that helps you
carve pornographic images into a pumpkin
pornographic images into a pumpkin yeah
the kit is being marketed under the name
the amish internet
that's how those guys do it
[Applause]
jacob jacob i found this pumpkin in your
room
i'm sorry father
uh it's being reported that although
hurricane sandy damaged thousands of
homes in new jersey the house used on
jersey shore was left completely
undamaged
in other words there is no god
i think that's proof right that's all
you need i think that's true
crazy story the lat this is real the
laptop used by bill clinton while he was
president is up for sale
yeah
yeah just a tip you might want to clean
it first
there are
as you would with any used product you
buy
[Applause]
and he's a perv uh
they're me
they cut to me because i thought you
said andy
they thought you're a perv yeah you said
and he's a perv but they thought you
said andy's approved
[Applause]
all i know is when i was mentioning the
pornographic pumpkin kit i saw you going
like this
uh there are rumors that the wife of
north korean dictator kim jong-un is
pregnant
yeah
so finally a successful missile launch
from north korea
[Applause]
due to the
tough economy two of the world's biggest
publishing houses have decided to merge
and become one yeah two of the biggest
publishing houses are merging
in fact they're only going to publish
one book this year fifty shades of harry
potter
can we have a can we have a little pervy
pervy voldemort maybe
[Applause]
i'm going to spank you with your wand
now i'd like you to meet nagini
it's my favorite impression
kelsey grammer said that he brought his
three-month-old daughter to a party at
the playboy mansion
because he couldn't find a good
babysitter
yeah then again most of kelsey grammer's
marriages ended because he did find a
good babysitter
[Applause]
oh
judging it a bit and then liking it